[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com one of the things that we've
been observing as we follow president
donald trump's handling as some are
calling it miss handling not handling as
others would call it of the coronavirus
situation is that both trumps approval
rating and his approval or the number of
people who believe he's specifically
handling the pandemic well are high and
that is a concern for a few different
reasons Donald Trump's job approval
rating is up five points in the latest
Gallup survey matches the high point of
his entire presidency and more than
fifty percent believed that Donald Trump
is handling coronavirus properly this is
driven not by Republicans the Republican
approval of Trump has remained very high
in the mid low to mid-90s for a very
long time but Donald Trump has gained
eight points among independents and six
points among Democrats so for those
simply saying this is because of
Republicans it's not in fact Trump's
approval among Republicans has remained
basically the same so I have a couple
theories Pat as to what may explain this
one is in moments of crisis in general
people rally behind the president that
that's true it has nothing to do with
what the president is actually doing and
we saw this after 9/11 with George W
Bush although he squandered it with the
Iraq war there are other examples of it
the other thing may be that in plate we
have a country that has very densely
populated areas and very sparsely
populated areas thirty-five or forty
percent of all the cases right now that
we that are confirmed are in New York in
New York State forty thirty five forty
percent of all the country so you have a
large swath of the swaths of the country
that have no or very few known cases now
remember if they tested more they might
have more cases it's conceivable that
you have independents and Democrats in
those parts of the country who look
around they don't hear about many cases
and so they say well Trump must be doing
something right because it's not here
yet
as the case
maybe those are my two ideas about
what's going on yeah I agree with those
theories especially the first one it
does seem that like we rally behind the
president in crisis times and that was
definitely true for George Bush in 9/11
but I think it's also because Trump has
been able to use this to his advantage
in some in some way like he's been able
to say that he did the right thing by
instituting a travel ban on China and
Europe and he did it early before anyone
else was willing to and even though we
take a look at how he's handled this
situation and we realized that he's
bumbling it and we realizing we realized
that the test scenario was absolutely
horrible and we should have had those
tests a lot earlier and he should never
have declined the the whose tests other
people just see it a different way and
he's able to sort of take advantage of
that I mean the both sides ISM the the
polarization is continuing even through
this crisis I wonder like what would it
take for people to say he really bungled
it because the the reality is as you're
pointing out there's no test case for
how it would otherwise go right like
Trump can say I been travel from China
early and that saved a lot of lives and
of course the truth is if he had done it
a week earlier it would have saved more
lives but we don't have there's no way
to verify that so there's always this
idea that it could have been worse if
Trump didn't do it and for a lot of
people maybe that is accurate to some
degree he banned travel from Europe if
he had waited one more week it would
have been much worse
so hey he did it a week earlier than he
could have and we're better off for it
like there's also an element of that
there's no other scenario to compare to
yeah exactly right and I think a few
weeks ago we thought that Trump's
election every election chances were
pretty strong right because he seemed to
match up well against Joe Biden we
thought but then last week I was
starting to think well if the economy's
in the toilet incumbent presidents tend
to not win reelection if that's the case
and you know many elections are decided
by the economy so you may not be able to
pull this thing off after all right now
I'm wondering well we see his soaring
approval numbers we see Joe Biden
basically hiding or when he does give
those rare press conferences and little
Weezer don't seem to go very well
they're strange yeah so yeah maybe maybe
he actually will be able to win
reelection despite the bad economic
situation I think will be in a November
I am increasingly am feeling and again
this is one of those things where
there's very little new polling coming
out it's really hard to know it's just
the feeling my feeling is that almost no
matter what given the most likely
outcomes like it's very unlikely that in
October the virus will still be steeply
growing as it is now it might take 8
weeks to reach the peak it might take
you know 12 we don't know when the peak
is going to be but no almost no matter
what Trump does it's looking like by the
election time it's not going to be as
acutely bad as it is now like watch me
eat my words if it doesn't work out that
way but there's a very good chance of
that I think that this is all helping
Trump getting reelected I really do
because again there's the the deniable
the plausible deniability of it was
better than if he had handled it even
worse at some point we will get past it
and there will be people who will say we
got past it under Trump so reelect them
again regardless of what the facts
actually are
yeah like Trump held up during a crisis
scenario and for the next four years we
probably won't experience the anything
as bad as we did with the coronavirus of
my Trump is the guy poor for us going
forward that may very well be true but
also as we go forward with this stuff
people are going to be more and more
personally impacted by it both by the
virus itself I'm sure many of us will
know people who get the virus maybe even
die from the crisis the virus and also
there gonna be plenty of people who lose
their jobs lose their incomes if they
haven't already so I wonder if because
people are going to be personally
impacted if that will maybe change their
minds because you know I think Trump is
able to get away with the the corruption
stuff the Russia stuff Ukraine stuff
because it doesn't personally impacts
people yeah
whereas this definitely does so maybe
that would change people's Tunes when
the bodies tragically start to stack up
metaphorically and if it's anything like
what's been going on in Italy literally
to some degree maybe this changes and
again I have no desire for that to
happen so that Trump gets hurt
politically I want to save every every
person that can be saved
but how does the rhetoric continue to
work if that starts to become a daily
headline I don't know we're just gonna
have to wait and see
one of
things we've been talking about is that
30 states are essentially doing nothing
yet in terms of physical distancing and
sheltering in place Louisiana's governor
actually did say no gatherings of more
than 50 people now here in Massachusetts
we the rule is no gatherings of more
than 10 50 is certainly much more
generous but there is a pastor Tony
spell who runs Life Tabernacle Church in
Baton Rouge he had a thousand people at
his services and actually achieved that
by bringing buses of people in from
across five parishes what is the point
here is is this to show that you were
defying what those [ __ ] liberals are
doing is it to show that I don't know
God is stronger than the virus or
something crazy like what is the point
of this I think it's the show that God
is stronger than the virus and if we all
come together and congregate in churches
and we pray like people are used to
doing that maybe this will all go away
and the the opposites appears to be true
I would imagine that people in his
parish will probably be impacted by this
many of them will probably get the
disease because they continue to
congregate they continue to avoid the
social distancing and there are people
saying that maybe this pastor should be
criminally charged yeah because this
does seem like reckless endangerment at
the very least I honestly think that
maybe he would like that because that
would make him seem like a martyr if he
goes to jail during all of this or after
all this is done I think many people
would see that as like wow he was
willing to put god above the law and
only smarter yeah he would immediately
say I am bringing Jesus to people and
they're putting me in prison and in fact
the police chief of the central police
department in Baton Rouge says that the
matter is under investigation the pastor
said to CNN that he believes the
pandemic is politically motivated and
it's of course it's like what is that
even are you saying the virus is
partisan is is the is the coronavirus
partisan because the idea of this I we
know what he means that the the motions
the the decisions being made by
governors are politically motivated that
it's being used you know to attack
Donald Trump or whatever the case may be
but you sound very dumb when you say
that the pant he's conceding it's a
pandemic he but he's saying it's a
politically motivated pandemic yeah and
how many people
to get the virus how many people have to
die before we all start taking this
seriously
and this pastors based out of Louisiana
Louisiana actually has experienced the
largest spike yeah cases out of anywhere
in the world of course New York has the
most like total cases in the u.s. right
now but we may very well see Louisiana
rivaled them and yeah I mean this is we
just can't do it alone I mean blue
states they do seem to be taking it
seriously we have the stay-at-home
orders we have the social distancing
measures but if the red states don't do
it as well I mean what what good is it
because you know people travel travel
all over the country and if you're not
practicing those measures elsewhere and
then you come to the blue states it's
going to screw over everyone and they're
all going to be in a terrible place in a
few months from now it's it's it's I I
have no clue where we're going to be in
a few months and I'm no longer
pretending to know because it really
what it's going to depend on what we do
and as we talked about on the show today
we won't keep talking about it Trump
wants the letter rip on on April 12th
let me tell you about some businesses
that are actually doing a lot of hiring
under the pandemic status quo I don't
think it'll surprise you what's going on
of course food and medicine are the
things people continue to need so
supermarkets are doing a lot of hiring
Kroger Albertsons doing a lot of hiring
pharmacies CVS Walgreens convenience and
discount stores Dollar General and
7-eleven and then of course the big
retail companies Amazon Walmart and
maybe to some degree target doing a lot
of hiring a grocery delivery services so
for example instacart says it's planning
to hire or they don't really hire
because they're not employees but
they're planning to enroll 300,000 new
workers to shop and deliver groceries
which is essentially doubling their
workforce
Walmart's saying we're hiring 150,000
Amazon hiring a hundred thousand a Papa
John's and pizza delivery companies
hiring thousands of people some of the
meal kit companies are starting to hire
more people and then also transportation
and logistics is hiring so it's it's
certainly bad for the economy overall
there are spots that are hiring and I
guess all we can really hope for
is that some of the this higher so so
you've got this big depression
essentially in employment the stimulus
is going to do something for some people
we talked today it looks like it's gonna
be 1,200 bucks to everybody making under
75 K and then it'll trail off up until
99 K then you're going to have it looks
like Trump letting it rip on April 12th
and some people are just going back to
work which seems like a terrible idea
and then you have some sectors that are
going to be hiring more people hopefully
this stuff is going to to some degree
mitigate what's going on of course
letting it rip on April 12th will also
cause way more people to get infected
and die seems to be a trade Trump is
willing to make at this point well I
mean we need these people to be working
right we need the cbs's to be open we
have the Walmarts to be open these are
essential roles after all but the the
workers there are putting themselves at
risk so they should be definitely
receiving some hazard pay not only are
they putting themselves at risk but
they're also putting their own families
at risk and that's a risk that people at
the top and those companies don't have
to take because they can work from home
they can work behind a desk and they
don't have to interact with the public
so you know we're used to seeing people
who work at grocery stores making seven
eight nine dollars an hour that should
probably be doubled at a time like this
I mean yes who knows if they can afford
it right now but they have to find a way
it seems like we're making uh other
things affordable when they previously
weren't under this crisis grocery stores
are making a ton of money and I have
successfully avoided going to the
grocery store for close to a week now
and I now today I am definitely going to
need to go and resupply on a bunch of
stuff and since the since I was last
there here in Massachusetts I've been
reading and anecdotally seeing that
there are a whole bunch of new rules one
in one out at a lot of places tape on
the floor as we talked about to keep
people spaced out but still a very very
busy in grocery stores doing well
despite the fact that people you know at
a certain point you would think the
hoarding has to slow down because people
have enough stuff the thing is it'll you
can very quickly have a second wave if
it looks like this is going to last
longer so I don't know what to expect
today when I go to the grocery store I
think there will still be waves of
hoarding because at first you had the
the Preppers hoarding and then you had
people who are like concerned about this
but aren't normally Preppers hoarding
and then you had people who were
usually not even concerned about stuff
like this they are hoarding so I think
we're gonna see more and more waves of
that stuff but I was also wondering like
the the benefits do seem to be pretty
generous that Congress is going to be
passing the unemployment insurance and
the universal payment of people making
under a hundred thousand dollars so I
wonder if like the average person who
got laid off if they would be even
willing to seek out employment like
wouldn't they it's gonna depend on the
case of course and what your individual
circumstance is like but I wonder if
people would rather just stay home stay
safe receive those checks for free and
instead of going out and trying to get a
new job I don't think so no I don't I
don't think so let me tell you why
number one twelve hundred bucks one-time
payment even if they make it monthly
that's fourteen thousand four hundred
dollars a year that's you know a
fraction of the average salary in the
United States number two you don't lose
anything by working anyway it's not one
of these things where you you lose up
the benefit again it's based on prior
income it's going to be based on what it
looks like it's gonna be based on 2019
taxes if you filed them in otherwise
2018 taxes so there's no risk that if
you start working in 2020 you lose out
on any of it so I don't know that it'll
do it'll do have that effect but what
about coupled with the unemployment
insurance like if you're getting maybe
$500 Oh from the state because of
unemployment and then the code federal
government tax on an extra $600 a week
maybe that would be worth it to you
maybe maybe you would make less money oh
yeah but you wouldn't be putting
yourself at risk well do you'd be making
it while doing nothing and potentially
that ya know that that's a fair point I
don't know the answer I don't know the
answer but I think you know the best I I
most people I think want to be working
they want to feel useful they don't want
to feel like that like all activity has
just stopped I have friends who are
working from home but for example they
work in event planning so like they have
15 minutes of work a day and a
conference call or two and they feel
like they're doing nothing and I think
generally speaking I think people want
to be working and these payments really
are going to hopefully just be a
temporary float for people and again I
don't want to do it too soon
but I look forward to when people can
get back to work I think letting it rip
on April 12th is too soon yeah I
generally agree with the sentiment that
people like to work
they want to be working you may not like
your job specifically but people want to
be productive right so I definitely get
that and I don't buy that as an argument
against universal basic income or these
other social welfare benefits but in a
time like this when it's dangerous just
to go outside especially into public
areas maybe they would be a little able
to say I like working and I generally
like being productive right now I got a
hunker down and stay at home what the
government wants them to do as Trump
said we usually pay people to work now
we're paying people not to work this
staying home is actually what we want
them to do in this particular case so
we'll see how it shakes out I still
don't even understand the mechanism
through which you like sign up for the
payment that's not been made clear for
people who haven't filed 2019 tax
returns there's the idea that you would
get it with filing they would it would
add twelve hundred bucks there but a lot
of people have filed already and I
actually don't they need to announce
that at some point like an you go to a
website and say send me the money or how
does it all work well if you haven't
done your taxes in a few years right
are those people gonna get paid and that
I would imagine that's a significant
portion of the country what are you
going to do with them those probably the
people who need it the most right now
and are they gonna be penalized because
they didn't file their taxes I think
what is it you have to do it every few
years or so but not every year I don't
know yeah I don't know the rules I've
always gonna be a lot of people in that
boat yeah what will fit we'll figure it
out we'll let you know when we know that
tonight 8 p.m. Eastern remember it's the
David Pakman show chess tournament I am
the 2019 champion
there was only one game i beat pat once
and i that made me the champion but now
we will have the 2020 Chess Championship
tonight on Lee chess org Pat will be
playing and we hopefully I I think I'm
being conservative when I say 50 people
will play we may have way more than that
and that would be very very cool yes and
I am indeed going to be playing I'm
going to take back what's rightfully
mine
I think the 2019 championship game
between you and me was rigged and we're
gonna have a second shot at it I'm going
to be able to reclaim my title
it's all happening tonight if you don't
want to play but you want to watch I'll
be streaming my games starting at 8:00
p.m. Eastern Time we'll see you then
or tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]